FEMALE SPEAKER: Computing
has had an enormous impact
on all of our lives.
Every day 100 of millions
of users around the world
use mobile and web apps.
And a number of the
groundbreaking, innovative work
was done by
development agencies.
DAVID MCLAUGHLIN:
Google recognizes
the impact these agencies
have an overall [? apica ?]
system globally.
These agencies employ
tens to hundreds
of talented developers each.
They design and publish
dozens of the top apps
globally, every single year.
MUSTAFI ALI: Mutual Mobile
is a [? regional ?] agency
that builds products for
Fortune 500 companies
using emerging technologies.
We work for large companies.
We also work with
small start-ups.
PRADEEP NALLURI: We are
headquartered in Austin, Texas.
We are a 200 office in Austin,
and we are 35 in India.
Our plan is to triple our
work force in India by 2017.
RAVI KORUKONDA: We started
Purple Talk in 2008, just when
mobile industry is born.
So we did more than
600 applications
in the last seven years.
We're the only company in India
who work with Hollywood IT.
We did it again for
"Madagascar" movie,
and also we did it again
for "Star Trek" movie.
AMIT SANJEEV: In
recognition of the impact,
the [? Developers ?]
relations team
has created a specific program
to cater for their needs.
Here, we try to help them
create work products that
are high quality,
and also help them
improve their productivity.
PARUL SOI: In the first event,
[INAUDIBLE] conducted in India,
we worked with
over 350 developers
across six different cities.
UMA SHANKAR
MALLAPRAGADA: I'm really
impressed with the
initiative that Google
has taken towards building
their relationship
with various partners
who are really engaged
in the mobile app development,
specifically on Android
and help us really
build any work-arounds
around technological
complexities
and probably how they integrate
the ads, how they have
the tools in the app
to basically scale when
their customer base grows up.
AMIT SANJEEV: In
these events, we
touch upon different aspects,
including technology, design,
and process engineering.
Using these events, we
hope that developers
can create better products
and also create experiences
that can delight users.
BALASUBRAMANIAN KJ: Decisions
that they're taking out today,
it's going to help us in
the overall development
for Android.
We got a lot of insights about
Android M then Android L,
and the kind of [? bridges ?]
that we're going
to use for our development.
AMIT RANA: It's a good start,
so that every developer
is at a common
level, so that we can
get into more advanced
sessions in the future.
So what I'm expecting to get
that information from Google.
What are the specific trainings?
Whether we should be
doing hybrid or native?
What are big players doing?
Also, input which
would help our UNIX
team to give a better
experience to what customers
want to build.
UTTAM TRIPATHI:
We started working
with agencies in
the UK and India,
and now expanding to
additional regions.
By using our understanding
of various markets,
we localize our
content and offerings,
hence ensuring it's still
made for each of our partner
agencies.
NARENDRA: I am happy that Google
came up with Google Developer
agency program by
coming to our company
and talking to the
Android developers,
and also taking
feedback from us.
PRADEEP NALLURI: I
think this will greatly
help us to build
great applications
and make the ultimate user
experience good for the end
customers.
I think it's a good thing
to do at the end of the day.
DAVID MCLAUGHLIN:
The more streamlined
we can make their work,
the more high-quality apps
are available on
handsets for everyone.